[Musique]
depuis un mois personne ne peut rentrer
dans l'apôt travailler parce qu'il y a
des risques de noyade le sel est au fond
du du lac car ça ne peut prolonger pour
vous exploiter le sel ça c'est un
problème et deuxièmement si ce phénomène
perdure on risque de perdre complètement
le sel parce que par dissolution c'est
un problème parce qu'il y a tellement
d'eau douce dans la laque ça continue
comme ça donc il sera des problèmes
l'exploitation du sol va disparaître une
bonne fois pour toute
[Musique]
ça fait presque 30 ans on est là mais on
n'a jamais vu cette Dolo là ici et c'est
très difficile pour nous parce que nous
on travaille ici pour nourrir avec les
enfants tout ça parce qu'on a on connaît
seulement ça ici il y a pas autre
travail on travaille seulement ici dans
le village artisanal pour gagner la vie
[Musique]
elle est rose à cause des algues et les
micro-organismes je dis bien des
microbes organismes qu'on appelle des
bactéries exemple avec ce taux là on
peut pas avoir du sel dans le lac et les
seuls jours très important pour la
concentration et la couleur rose donc
s'il y a plus il y a plus de sel on peut
plus avoir la chlorure
la date la destination du Sénégal va
avoir des problèmes parce que la
création rose et l'exploration de sel
pouvait amener beaucoup de monde à venir
découvrir donc là c'est une perte pour
nous les artisans c'est une perte pour
toutes les instigraphes autour de l'acte
mais aussi c'est une pâte pour le
Sénégal économiquement
[Musique]